The first book is the Adweek Copywriting
Handbook by Joe Sugarman. This is the
101 copywriting must-read essential
banger that every person should have. I
don't want you to buy a course, I don't
want you to buy a coach, anything like
that. Read this book first. You got to
read it and understand all the
copywriting fundamentals. The second
book is Storyworthy by Matthew Dicks,
okay? The best storytellers are the
people who own the internet. If you just
post a bunch of value posts and ChatGPT
copy posts, that's why the internet is
saturated with a bunch of mediocre
creators. The best creators tell the
best stories, and this book will help
you tell great stories. Next is
Cashvertising by Drew Whitman. This is a
more advanced copywriting tactics,
really into persuasion and sales,
offers, and all the things that you need
to actually make a ton of money with
your brand, but this shouldn't be read
until you read Adweek Copywriting
Handbook, then you can dive into this
baby. And then Everybody Writes by Ann
Handley. This is super underrated
because most copywriters under value the
art of writing itself. There's so much
emphasis on persuasion and sales that
they do not think about formatting and
tone and structure and the things that
actually make reading digestible and fun
and sticky on the internet. This is a
great one to help you do that. And then
lastly, one of the best is The Art and
Business of Writing Online by Nicolas
Cole. This is like an an
all-encapsulating how-to guide of really
building and monetizing your writing
business online, gives you some great
writing tips. Honestly, just one of the
best books you can read ever.